développement de réponse avec Look ici
là à Shanghai
les entreprises chinoises font face à un
dilemme si elle ne respecte pas les
sanctions économiques contre la Russie
elles risquent des représailles de leur
partenaire européen et américains ça
pourrait prendre la forme de très
lourdes amandes voir de poursuites
contre les dirigeants de ces entreprises
en revanche si elles appliquent
effectivement ces sanctions alors ces
entreprises iraient à l'encontre du
gouvernement chinois puisque Pékin
condamne les sanctions contre la Russie
il est donc probable qu'avant d'agir les
entreprises chinoises attendent un feu
vert un signal clair de la part du Parti
communiste chinois mais pour l'instant
Pékin ne s'oppose pas frontalement à
Washington et à Bruxelles pourtant les
opportunités économiques pour les
entreprises chinoises en Russie sont
énormes la Chine c'est déjà le premier
partenaire économique russe notamment
dans le domaine technologique par
exemple Moscou importe environ 70% de
ses semi-conducteurs depuis la Chine
pour les téléphones portables le chinois
Xiaomi et le deuxième vendeur sur le
marché russe son concurrent Apple a
cessé ses activités en aussi si le
coréen Samsung part aussi alors Xiaomi
et d'autres entreprises chinoises auront
le champ libre a noté également que la
Chine et la Russie viennent de signer
pour la construction d'un nouveau
gazoduc c'est donc une nouvelle voie
pour les exportations de gaz russe face
aux canaux bloqué en Europe les deux
pays ont également signé plusieurs
contrats énergétiques ces dernières
semaines et ces contrats ils sont signés
en yen et pas en dollars et ça ça permet
à Moscou de contourner les sanctions
bancaires du camp occidental